imaginez le défi comment attirer
l'attention lorsque l'on se présente
dans la circonscription du premier
ministre le candidat néo-démocrate de
calgary en alberta trouve une façon peu
ordinaire de s'attaquer à son principal
adversaire
regardez bien les explications de
ludovic bourdages mcmaster burgener est
un candidat néo démocrate dans un
bastion conservateur la circonscription
calgary héritage de trouver une façon
assez originale d'amasser des fonds et
surtout d'attirer l'attention
en échange d'un don de 50 $ à sa
campagne et les électeurs peuvent écrire
un message personnel à stephen harper un
message qui est ensuite retranscrits sur
une pancarte et les pancartes sont
disposés tout autour de celle de son
adversaire et les messages sont plutôt
drôles on trouve par exemple des
messages comme steven c'est pas toi
c'est moi ou encore on doit parler de ta
coupe de cheveux comment ça fonctionne
sur le site scène un peu à message
les électeurs peuvent choisir l'un des
huit commentaires suggéré ou encore et
peuvent écrire leurs propres messages de
50 caractères qui sera retranscrit avec
un petit logo du npd en prime
mais gare aux insultes car elles ne
seront pas affichées le but ici est
d'interpeller directement stephen harper
après avoir constaté qu'il passait peu
de temps dans sa circonscription
l'initiative qui respectent la loi
électorale a suscité peu d'intérêt de la
part du camp conservateur si ce n'est de
dire que cet événement à peu se
concentre sur l'économie pendant la
campagne
mine de rien le npd a réussi à amasser
plus de dix mille dollars en moins d'une
semaine il ya plus de 200 affiches qui
ont été placés si certains trouvent que
c'est une idée originale ben y en a
d'autres qui peuvent sembler jaloux
parce qu'on a appris cette semaine qu'il
ya une trentaine d'affichés qui ont été
volés